I used to round five banks a day six
days a week then on the day off items a
pickpocket I can't think of anything I'd
love to do more on my day off then go
jellyfishing with my two best friends
SpongeBob and Patrick ride
bodkin hey nephew I was looking for you
at your home oh yeah dad told me to take
the day off so I decided to come into
work Oh I normally do but this week on
my day off I'm doing a walkathon for
illiteracy we're against it this
Memorial Day let's focus on those other
ways to enjoy a day off new york times
smarter living editor Tim Herrera has
some ideas in this morning's newsletter
hit step 1 give yourself permission to
actually take the day off this is a big
one cuz people walk around with their
phones in their pocket they've got their
emails on there mhm they're reading the
news they're trying to pay attention to
research reports all the rest so yes
actually take the day off actually take
the day off message to your bosses in
your tongue didn't get the memo people
you edit they're also but happen to be
here working on my day off but ya know
but it's so difficult for us to actually
take ourselves out of the mindset of
always being on and their studies show
that you know Americans send something
like only 40 percent fewer emails on
holiday Mondays compared to regular
status that's a crazy town to each other
though right it's it's just a cycle but
we need to be ok with accepting the day
for what it is which is a day off don't
need to check your email don't need to
be responding the world is not gonna end
if we're not on our phones the whole day
why why shouldn't I do this so there's a
lot of studies that show that actually
building laziness and building idle time
into your schedule and into your regular
routine can actually in this weird
roundabout way make you more productive
so there's research that was just
published in the research of creativity
and it showed that taking time off and
letting your brain be kind of lazy and
wander and just kind of go off and
whatever daydreams you have you can
actually make us more creative you can
make us better problem solvers can
actually help us have better and more
creative ideas in the long run I think
it also helps you focus and sort of
rearrange
priorities and get make sense of the
world absolute we all need time to just
relax and chill out
everything let's talk about family time
being important in it and when you take
a day off yeah so one thing that I think
is really important for people do you
want a day off is do things that maybe
you wouldn't do normally and so one of
those things that I think you'll be
really important is having family time
and so you Americans generally eat about
70 percent of their meals outside of the
home and so a day off is kind of a good
excuse for us to kind of gather the
family around yes doesn't have to be an
elaborate meal could be ordering pizza
what really matters is that we're just
having concerted I did this last night
mind my daughter challenged me to take
the phone and put it aside you do it I
did very difficult I said have to do a
show in the morning we don't have our
phones and then after noon we played
cards against humanity' which is a whole
different story but you know it seems
when you say do something you normally
wouldn't do you would think that you
would normally do stuff with your family
but it is getting to the point where
we're so splintered now that that
becomes a thing to do yeah it could be
actual occasion yeah I'm a fewer than
half of American families have a regular
family dinner 20 of those Center eating
in the car used to 20 percent of meals
are eaten in the best horrible like
clean the refrigerator I didn't get that
clean the fridge again it's one forgive
somebody normally do forgive somebody
and a really important why is that
important cleaning the fridge if I could
interject it they are the therapeutic
power of cleaning cannot be overstated
be reckoned with that all right we
should point out this Memorial Day right
serve this country are there particular
things that you can do on that front
today sure so there's a website for a
nonprofit called give well it's give
well org and what they do is evaluate
organizations based on how much good
results from each dollar spent and so
for people who are looking to get
involved with charity that can be
generally a pretty good place to start
and also go through the closet mariko
know your closet get a couple of bags of
clothes and go do you think that's good
I'm stuck on the forgive why you think
that's important because can you forgive
and not be mad you can't so I
wrote a story about this about the power
forgiveness in holding on to grudges and
not forgiving people can actually have a
physical repercussion it can increase
stress hormones in your system it can
contribute to cardiovascular disease and
so we hold on to this tension and this
anger and so kind of letting go of that
is really about freeing yourself it's
less about the person you're forgiving
it's more about letting yourself be free
from the kind of hold that they have
over you although if someone's angry at
you I don't know if you're gonna win
them over about being like you know it'd
be really good for your heart if you
give me a break on this maybe you can
clean the fridge good that but it really
does make sense
it really does yeah you also talked
about using using a day off as a chance
to to to do something you've been
avoiding yeah so doing the kind of one
thing that's hold it's kind of the
monkey on your back right we all have
these things that are kind of in the
background we know we need to do but
we're putting them off what I think
about what they can't fall asleep you
know they right I haven't done this yes
exactly yeah we least could have known
at us and so you know for me like a day
off is a good excuse just to get them
done and it's so funny that so many of
these tasks are just kind of small
menial little things maybe send email
you have to send a thank-you card we're
just getting it done and out of the way
is such a relief and you feel better
about yourself about if you're currently
on the couch watching us and you don't
wanna do anything all day that's fine do
they like you to do that creative best
way to spend the day in my opinion thank
you smarter living editor become a
smarter and messing up a whole life and
trying to fix it all holiday